you had one of my favorite moments on
our show that was spontaneous where you
were out on the we were chatting
together
on the show you were paneling you were
talking and something there was a low on
the conversation
things got quiet for just a second and
you looked around you said
where is our waiter
[Applause]
I love that that was you're so good with
silences I guess you'd have to be you
know no kidding around I'm used to
silence and as a stand-up comic
season stand-up comic
I don't mind silence as you're starting
off silence is bad because you're
insecure and you feel like you have to
keep going
I've been silenced for like a half hour
on stage
people don't say anything because they
know
I'm formulating ideas and I'll be coming
back strong with something or your mind
is buying or I'm just blanking out yeah
because it's the most yeah common reason
as we've seen today yeah that there
could be issues
what do you really want to do Conan I'm
being really serious are you happy with
this what's that podcast
or was it a web series or a podcast
I think we'd call it by the way my
hiking show airs on YouTube yeah uh-huh
we've talked about it no we didn't talk
about YouTube on my own channel I have a
YouTube channel believe it or not oh
congratulations are you happy with that
very happy very happy are you fulfilled
you should be you're one of the funniest
people I know you have as I said a
lovely wife uh a a very good looking uh
funny intelligent son you've got it all
you're right
wait why do I come here well you're here
to see me because I know you admire me I
know that you think I'm one of the uh
all-time funniest people you've ever met
now that's just you know you really have
to kind of uh you really have to
um assess the situation I have
everything yet I drive across town to
come here
because I worry about you oh what are
you worried about
stress your stress level have you had
like your what's your blood pressure my
blood pressure is very good I don't know
the numbers you're taking like 20 pills
right no I don't have high blood
pressure I went to my doctor a couple of
days ago true story he took my blood
pressure and this is what they always
say wow nice that's what doctors always
say about my blood pressure I have very
good blood pressure what's bad about you
well I guess my intentions
my plans how is your cholesterol
cholesterol is okay it's pretty good you
never hear it wow nice about that no I
don't hear why not wow no I hear huh
okay I had my when I was on The Simpsons
uh wait for Applause
okay and I worked on The Simpsons
and um they had a cholesterol a van came
to the fox lot and everyone got a free
cholesterol test and everyone went and
got their cholesterol
and I got mine
I was I think 24. it was so high that
the nurse offered to walk me back to the
office
yeah it was like practically 300. what
happened why was it that high uh I think
just uh I was uh very
um it's funny it doesn't really I don't
think runs in my family so uh they and
then someone told me that stress now you
remember me back in the day I was a
tightly wound very tightly wound guy uh
who would rub the my fingers together I
was I was burning I was a burning coal
you have no fingerprints anymore you've
rubbed them so many that's why I've
committed so many successful murders uh
but I believe that uh stress was a big
part of it oh definitely but I'm much
better now much better it's not genetic
no I don't think it's genetic does it
run in your family no I said that
earlier and you weren't listening
um
what is the age because we're talking
about life and disease so I'm not just
springing a different topic on you what
is the age where people don't ask when
somebody dies what happened you know
it's like is it 82 I think you got to be
well into your 80s now people live
longer everyone says what happened uh my
brother Neil will say what happened
if
you know Norman Lear just turned 100. if
he lives another seven years and then
passes away quietly in his sleep and I
call my brother Neil and say Norman Lear
passed away at 107 Yale's gonna go what
happened oh he's like the only person he
does that he does that every time and I
say well he was on his motorcycle and he
ran into an Exxon tank and it exploded
yeah I mean you know I don't know what
he wants from me but he always says what
happened yeah the person could be 95 a
98. what happened what happened well I
think it's maybe 85 now was it so
essentially
you could kill somebody over 85 you can
murder them and nobody will investigate
that's not true don't I I want to be a
responsible from my experience no I want
to be a responsible podcaster and I want
to say that that's not the case that uh
when the police show up and there's an
88 year old lying there and there's a
chainsaw halfway through their head uh
and a note that says I finally got you
ha ha enjoy hell they're going to
investigate they're going to investing
that's all natural causes right there
not natural causes yeah the note is not
in the victim's handwriting and
um there's a PS that says I love to
murder
it could be a comic okay got it take a
break we'll be right back listen you've
met them all
you've met them all you've met you've
met Johnny Carson obviously and and you
got to be a guest on Carson show of
course there are a lot of young people
that don't understand the significance
of that but that was a very different
time if you went on Johnny Carson it was
a huge deal and you were sort of
anointed a star by just by being on his
show well I never got a star
do you have a star in the Hollywood Walk
of Fame
I I do not I okay good
um yeah you know it's funny because
Johnny Carson
can we be serious Johnny Carson uh was
like the guy at the talk show King he
was the only one really he validated you
as a comic yeah and you'd have that on
the top of your bio yeah you know and
then as time went by
you lower it down the list of things
you've done and then all of a sudden you
take it off because it dates you yeah
and so Johnny Carson is no longer
on my resume really I'd keep it on
forever
yeah I uh I'm always ready to go I have
one in my trunk of my car just in case
things hit the fan who was the first
famous celebrity you ever met or saw I
want to say it was James Coburn we I
think we talked about this on an earlier
episode oh
um I was a kid and he was uh James
Coburn he was the best was shooting a
movie charade
no he was shooting just trying to help
you you're not really uh and they were
shooting a scene outside my dad's
hospital and my dad brought us all down
to watch and uh why was your dad in
hospital what would you have a doctor he
had a career there that's what he had
and
um yeah my dad was in the hospital
clinging to life saw James Coburn and he
was the dragged out of bagged himself
out of the hospital uh and uh and made
us all come and then went back to his
operation but anyway we watched James
Coburn he had to walk up to a car and
all he had to do was open the uh car
door
and get in
or and that he went to do it and uh the
car door was locked and he couldn't get
in and then I watched the crew spend 45
minutes with a coat hanger trying to
open it and I thought
this is the business I want to be in
this is Magic
do you want to know who I saw not really
I think I'm good do you know so when
somebody asks you a question they really
want you to ask them oh I know I know
you know I don't care who you saw no I'm
going to play along like somebody
sometimes somebody will say well I'll
get to it sometimes somebody will say to
me what do you what do you if you can
improve anything with me what do you
think it should be what they really want
to say is I'd like to improve some
things about you ask me you know ask me
to you know what you would like the
first celebrity I've ever seen uh or
famous person was John F Kennedy Believe
It or Not how'd you see John F Kennedy I
was probably seven at the time and we
lived in Germany and he was uh I guess
on his way to Berlin and he was in to
give the famous speech yeah
why do you keep interrupting me
see what goes around comes around
so we're at this Air Force Base because
we knew he was going to be there and
everybody was there and he drove by in
that Lincoln that convertible Lincoln he
was waving and we actually have a movie
uh an eight millimeter of him you're
kidding yeah color of black and white we
colorized it nicely done nicely done the
Crayons with crayons now let me finish
did you say crowns cribs crayons crayons
no what's wrong with you it's it's
crayons how do you say o-f-t-e-n often
often no it's often no no how could it
be crayons and not often
okay the second celebrity I saw was
Carrie Grant at the uh JFK he was on the
back of a golf cart Oh I thought you
said he was chasing JFK
I thought I said because you weren't
listening again I thought JFK drove by
and then and Gary was running behind him
he's down a minute JFK it's me
too deep give a fella a lift